- [Narrator] Abandoned
for the last 53 years,
this eerie whaling station stands remote,
rusted, but reclaimed by the wildlife
it once hunted to near extinction.
Welcome to Grytviken.
(relaxed electronic music)
Grytviken was a working whaling station
on the British island of South Georgia,
located 1,500 miles away
from the foot of Argentina.
Founded in 1904, the vacated settlement
was once the largest
whaling station in the area.
Over 60 years, over 175,000 whales
were killed on the island,
out of which nine million barrels of oil
was produced from the
blubber, meat, and bone.
The station closed in 1966,
after the local whale
populations were decimated.
But there is hope for the
wildlife on this island.
Beyond Grytviken, the island as a whole
is thought to be the
most important penguin
and bird breeding area in the world,
hosting over three
million penguins a year.
And the whales are making a comeback.
Although their populations are thought
not to be fully recovered, the waters
are now a vibrant whale sanctuary.
The island stands as a testament
to the natural world's great gift
to bounce back and reclaim
what was once theirs.